On February 13, The Batman director Matt Reeves
took to Twitter to share the first camera
test for the upcoming comic book adaptation
in which Robert Pattinson plays the Dark Knight.
It doesn't show very much of Pattinson's face,
but what the video lacks in direct face-time,
it makes up for in epic slow-motion pans of
Pattinson's Batman suit.
The clip is soaked in red light, and begins
with Pattinson walking toward the camera as
it focuses on the bat insignia on his costume.
As he turns to one side, we get a peek of
the shoulder pieces of the new suit and a
taste of the Battinson cape.
Then, finally, the lower half of Pattinson's
face comes into focus, with the upper half
shielded by his Batman mask.
Given the day it was dropped and its candy-red
color palette, this first video of Pattinson's
Batman could be considered something of a
Valentine's Day present from Reeves and the
folks at Warner Bros.
Pictures.
From our vantage point, it looks as though
the film's team may have been inspired by
a few different versions of Batman's iconic
suit when they were working on the design
for the new movie.
The short video Matt Reeves released shows
a mechanical-looking Batman logo.
In the 2015 video game Batman: Arkham Knight,
the Batsuit armor pieces would mechanically
tighten, align, or separate depending on what
Batman wanted to do.
Arkham Origins also featured several different
shoulder armor options for the Batman suit
that look similar to what's shown in the camera
test clip Reeves shared online.
In Batman: Gotham Knight, the 2008 anthology
film comprised of animated superhero shorts,
Batman rocked a popped collar and a chin guard
in the "Crossfire" segment.
Finally, in Gotham by Gaslight, an alternate-reality
Batman set in the 1880’s also wore a slightly
popped collar while battling against Jack
the Ripper.
There's even a theory going around that the
Batman insignia on this new suit is literally
made from pieces of the gun that killed Bruce's
parents.
So, that's metal.
Regardless of how the costume came together
and what pieces of past Batman media it might
be referencing, the important thing is that
Pattinson loves how it looks.
Speaking with Yahoo Entertainment in October
2019, Pattinson briefly gushed about his Batsuit:
"Matt has got a really awesome idea about
it.
I think this thing is going to be very, very
cool."
Luckily for everyone involved in The Batman,
reactions to the first camera test of Pattinson
in his Batsuit have been overwhelmingly positive.
ComicBook.com's Brandon Davis wrote in response
to Reeves' tweet:
"IT'S BEAUTIFUL."
YouTuber and podcast host Eddy Burback was
so impressed with the video that he asked
for Reeves' hand in marriage, writing:
"matt will you marry me"
After watching the camera test of Pattinson
as Batman, Awards Ace editor-in-chief Erick
Weber tweeted:
"CAN WE MAGICALLY MAKE IT 2021"
Finally, ReelBlend podcast co-host Kevin McCarthy
had a simple message for Reeves:
"Thank you, sir.
Hell yes."
Fans have reacted similarly, tweeting out
GIFs of people screaming with glee and straight-up
yelling to express just how happy they were
with the test footage.
One user tweeted:
"Thank you Matt Reeves.
I was like legit dying for Batman news.
Yes!!
Let's freaking go!!"
Another wrote:
"MATT REEVES .. I owe you my life.
This is magnificent.
Thank you.
Thank you."
Yet another fan was particularly intrigued
by the finer details of the suit, what role
it might play in the upcoming film, and the
prospect of how the costume would hold up
over the course of The Batman and beyond:
"The textures.
The stitches.
It's amateur, it's handmade.
It's just past the beginning of the Bat.
It's so beautiful.
I can't even imagine how the suit is going
to damage/evolve through the course of the
movies."
It's plain to see people are giddily picking
up what Reeves is putting down.
Even though The Batman is still incredibly
far out from its June 25, 2021 release date,
this first look at Robert Pattinson's version
of the character promises even better things
to come as the film gets closer to theaters.
We can't wait to see what the new version
of Gotham City looks like:
"This city... this city is a labyrinth, designed
to mock me!"
Expectations are high and the standard is
now set — we officially can't wait to meet
The Batman.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.